(upbeat music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits, the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
- And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
you could kind of call this a part two
to what we did last week
where we talked about all the ideas
that we've had that have
never seen the light of day.
- They failed. They fizzled out.
- They were rejected.
- We were rejected.
♪ Bu-duh-ba-ba-bow ♪
- Now let me also say
that some of the stuff
that we went through last week,
I thought about this after the fact,
some of those ideas we kind of rejected.
Like they didn't even make
it to the first level of,
or maybe they were
considered by like an agent
or someone who looked at
a list of ideas and said,
"Okay, this is the one that
I think might be viable."
So I didn't want to give the impression
that every single idea that
we went through last week,
we had sat down in a room
with a group of people
and pitched it to them
and it was rejected.
Some of them were, they were
all rejected on some level
but some just never,
like little baby birds
that never even got
pushed out of the nest.
They just came out of
the egg and then die.
- I don't like picturing a dead baby bird.
- A dead baby bird.
Some didn't even get out of the egg.
They're in the egg and
they die inside that egg.
- Okay. That's better.
- And then you just have a
dead bird inside of an egg.
- That's fine.
- It slowly rots.
- I'm cool with that.
- Well, hold on, that's
even grosser to me.
- No because it's in an egg.
- Because I eat eggs, I crack eggs
and I always have a fear,
every time I crack an egg,
I think to myself is there
going to be a bird in this one?
- That's why you need to
shine the light on it first.
- I don't want to do that.
- But the baby birds that are like out
and like they don't have any
feathers and they're like-
- They're cute, man.
They're like little dinosaurs.
- Their eyeballs are like
huge and like bruised.
They look like they're bruised all over.
- You look like you should be
talking with a German accent.
(laughing)
- I'm going for a different look today.
I found this sweater-
- But the combination of your
glasses and your sweater.
- I bought this sweater
cashmere, by the way.
- You look like...
- It is peach.
- What was the old SNL skit?
Sprockets. (laughing)
- Sprockets.
They wore black, man.
- I know, you look like-
- They didn't wear peach.
- The 2021 version of Sprockets.
- Hey, man.
- If Sprockets came back,
it would be peach.
- I look different.
but I looked at myself in
the mirror and I was like,
I think I look good.
- Hey, I didn't say you look bad.
- And then Christy came in-
- I said you look German.
- I was fully ready to come in.
Yeah. I've got different glasses on today.
My signature Link glasses.
- I heard about this.
- Broke.
- Yeah. Sorry about that by the way.
- And-
- I punched him.
- I've been wearing them for
a couple of months broken.
It's just, right here.
I just noticed one day the
lens just fell out in my hand.
And it's because part of the frame,
it just broke clear in two.
Now I can superglue it,
but consulting with Jenna
we're gonna take it to
a professional because-
- Right and they're gonna glue it.
(laughing)
- Right.
- And you're gonna pay 'em for it.
- I cannot buy another
replica of these go-to glasses
of mine that I've had for years.
Like four years ago,
I did buy a second pair-
- And he lost them.
No, they got stolen.
- I kept them in my car.
- Thanks for spoiling all
of my stories this morning.
- Wait, I mean, come on, man.
I'm just
continuing the conversation.
- That was the punchline.
And guess what?
It was stolen.
Yeah. Stolen out of my car
in my own freaking driveway.
My second pair of glasses.
- Sorry about that by the way as well.
- So that when this happens-
- You know what?
I should probably give those to you now.
- I still have my glasses.
- I stole those from you
so when you broke your other
ones, I could give them to you
and I think I've misplaced
them at this point.
- These aren't, I'm not sticking,
I'm not switching to these
'cause I don't like them enough but-
- It's a nice change of pace though.
- I thought, you know what?
It's a nice change of pace for the day,
I'm wearing this peach sweater.
- You look two or three IQ points smarter.
- Than you. Yeah, exactly.
And I was thinking, I
looked in the mirror-
- Than your previous self
is what I was getting at.
- I'm like hey, I kind
of got a different look,
but I think I like it.
I go downstairs and I'm like
ready to walk out the door.
And Christy looks at
me and I'm like, yeah,
she's gonna say, she's
gonna give me a compliment
or at least say, I'll look
like that guy from Sprockets.
- She's gonna laugh at you
probably is what she did.
- The first thing she said was,
"There's like a like
a red dot on your neck
and you got another one."
I actually put a little makeup on it
so you can't see it.
- Oh, pull it out again,
what in the world?
- Is it there?
- Yeah. You got a rash.
- I don't know what that is.
Maybe it's from the sweater.
You got, pull it down again.
Yeah. You got a rash man.
- I actually feel, I think
it's just that I'm flush.
I'm kind of wired this morning.
- Oh.
- Anyway.
- 'Cause you went to the gym.
- I'm in the market to some new-
- You went to the gym and
you got your heart rate up.
- That's what it is. Yeah. Maybe.
- Yeah.
- I'm in the market for some new glasses,
but I'm gonna get as close to
my go-to glasses as I can get
because going this far away,
I never wear them because they're too far.
- Well-
- Too far from the real me.
- And speaking of being too far,
we went kind of far a field there.
What I was getting to was-
- Uh-huh.
- What we're going to talk about today is
how we've dealt with
that rejection, you know?
More on an emotional level
and what that has done to us.
Years of having things,
you know, rejected,
multiple things that we can
never bring to the light of day.
- Or things that were
brought to the light of day
that then, I mean, are
considered failures.
Like how do you move on after failure
from a creative standpoint?
- Yeah.
- So we'll discuss that.
- I do want to give you an update
on one of my children.
- Choose one.
- I'll pick the older one.
And so I think we've covered the fact
that our kids got a little bit later start
with the whole getting their
driver's license thing.
It's a generational thing.
Kids are not rushing
on their 16th birthday
to get their license,
at least not in Los Angeles,
I guess because of Uber.
And then COVID of course
had a pretty large impact
on everybody's plans.
- Yeah.
- Like for Locke,
it was he needed to
get his driving lessons
and then once COVID hit,
it was like, well, you can't.
We don't really want
you to get into the car
with somebody right now.
So, but anyway, since we're coming out
on the other side of that,
he's got his permit
and so he can drive us around.
Now, Jessie-
- Even though he is now,
he's already 17.
- He's already 17.
He could have had his license long ago.
- 15 and a half.
He could have-
- right.
- He could have taken his
drive, what he's doing now.
- And every day he tells
me how much he regrets
not going with the original schedule.
And I say, "This is why I
told you 100 times at least
that you should do this."
He was like, "I know, sometimes
I just have to learn things
the hard way, Dad.
- Damn, that's a milestone, man.
I mean, that right there is
what every parent lives for.
The when you say that I told you so,
and they're like, "You're right."
Like how often does that happen?
- Well often in my house.
No, no, actually.
- Oh, God it doesn't.
- No, it's interesting
because it is happening
more lately with him.
Like I thought that there would be things
that would be like, okay, you know,
when he's-
- Is it a pill that I
can get my kids to take?
- When he's like 28 he'll
come home for Christmas
and he'll be like, "You know what?
You guys were actually
pretty good parents."
You know?
- Yeah.
- But he actually, I
told you this yesterday,
he recently said, "I've
actually realized recently
that you guys are actually
pretty good parents."
(laughing)
And you just got to understand-
- What?
Did you get suspicious,
like what do you want?
- No, he wasn't asking for anything.
He was just experiencing some things with
other parents and stuff
and has points of reference and stuff.
And he's, you know,
appreciating his own parents.
So-
- Oh, us?
You talking about the me and Christy?
- Yeah, the Neals.
(both laughing)
No.
So anyway, so he is driving now
and Jessie had this stipulation.
She was like, "I'm not driving with him.
You can drive with him."
Her and Locke tend to
kind of get into it sometimes.
And I get only imagine
and she could only imagine
what it would be like if she's trying to,
you know, the classic
trope of the new driver
and the parent in the passenger
seat losing their mind.
- It's funny 'cause Christy said
the same thing about Jessie.
- Said what?
- That she wasn't going to ride with him.
- Yeah. Well, can you
imagine Jessie's offspring?
But it's also my offspring,
so I was like, okay.
I mean, then that means that
we're just gonna be driving
on the weekends 'cause that's
like the time that I've got
in order to do this.
And so the first couple
of like driving lessons
were going to a big parking lot
and getting the basics of
the car down, like, okay,
this is, you know, literally...
You know, when we grew up,
we had driven like golf carts
and go-carts and four wheelers.
We had a lot of driving experience.
My kid's a city kid.
It's just, he's come up different.
And so there wasn't like
all this driving experience
that you could just
transfer over to a car.
So it was a little bit like, oh,
the gas is here and the brake is here?
Like we were literally at that point.
- And I'm just, I'm basically just getting
through that point with a
Lincoln who is, you know,
he just turned 16 and you
take him to a parking lot
and for the reason you're talking about,
there's not a big parking lot
that you can find that's empty.
- There's like five other people.
- And then there's at
least four other cars
just like parked or lurching slowly.
- Yeah.
- And so that actually seems worse
because it's like all these cars
are just gonna lurch into each other
'cause they don't know the difference
between the gas and the brake.
- This is actually a great time.
I mean, the traffic is picking up,
but I would say that
a couple of months ago
when we started doing
these little adventures,
LA traffic is as low as it's ever been
in the history of our
10 years of being here,
but probably in the past 30,
40 years, because of COVID.
So-
- But if you want to
experience going back,
you can watch the latest Tarantino movie.
It has a lot of LA driving.
That's basically all I
remember about the movie.
- Which one?
- That and Brad Pitt on LSD.
- Oh. The Hollywood...
- "Once Upon a Time... In Hollywood"
- So anyway, so yeah, so we
did the parking lot thing
and I wasn't too confident.
I was like,
I wanted him to get
the feel of like, okay,
this is how you pull up
into a parking space.
This is how you back out.
And this is how you put the brakes on,
you shift the gears and you're...
Getting those, the
transitional points of driving
which is a really big part of driving.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Just being on a road and
going straight and stopping
and then starting again,
that's not driving.
- That ain't driving.
Yeah, I remember telling,
I was telling Lincoln,
I was like, he was in the driver's seat
and I realized I needed to tell him
what to do with his hands in
order to turn a 90 degree turn.
- Same thing.
- And I'm like,
"Well, you're supposed to grab."
And I told him what to do
based on what I thought I would do.
And then I was like, I
was like, "You know what?
Pull over.
I think what I'm telling
you is not what I do."
And I was totally right.
It's like, you think you should,
you're supposed to like
grab hand over hand.
And then when I did it,
I was like doing something
totally different.
- Right.
- Now, I just want to get
a timeline straight here
with your story with Locke,
because you have told the story
of when we went to Death Valley,
you let him drive in the desert,
which was like a series of-
- Well, that was the first time,
that was the first time he ever drove.
(Link laughing)
And it was a little bit traumatic.
- Right. So.
- And I was a little bit worried,
like is he gonna be okay?
Well, when we got back from Death Valley
and you know, he actually,
he didn't have his permit
at that time I don't think.
- And Lincoln still doesn't,
that's why we're only in a parking lot.
- So, but now he has it and
so we're able to like legally
let him drive, not just in
the middle of the desert.
So he did the parking lot thing
and there was a couple
of times where I was,
you know, sometimes you find yourself
becoming the stereotypical dad
who's like yelling and saying things
that you're gonna regret
and you kind of catch yourself.
You're like, ah, I feel like
I'm on a sitcom right now.
Like I'm Murray Goldberg
or whatever, you know?
And-
- Some grunting.
The occasional fart.
- But he was doing pretty good.
And so then I was like, all right,
well, let's take this out
into the neighborhood.
- Mm-hmm.
- So we kind of drove around
some like quiet neighborhood streets.
- Yep.
- And then I realized that that,
so he was coming to stops abruptly.
Like we would stop and he'd
be going a little bit too fast
and he would stop.
And then even he was going
a little bit too slow
when he would come to a
stop and roll to a stop,
there would be like a jerk.
- That moment where the
brakes totally seize.
- Totally seize.
And then when he takes off, he would go,
and then I found myself-
- You feel your brain hitting
the back of your skull every time, yup.
- I found myself becoming my dad.
You know, my dad didn't just
tell you how to do things.
He like, there was like a
second level of like style
that he thought was important.
- It was philosophical.
- So I was like, "Locke,
listen, I'm gonna tell you
as I teach you to drive,
I'm going to tell you a lot of things
that are going to make you a
better than average driver.
That's your goal is to
be better than average."
Right?
And I was like, "There's a lot of people
who are never going to learn
some of the intricacies
that I'm gonna teach you.
- Yes.
- And then one of the things
is I'm gonna teach you
is the smooth
- Yes.
- To be smooth.
- And there's three ways
that you can be smooth in a car.
- Uh-huh.
- Okay?
The first way is stopping.
The second way is going.
And the third way, the third way-
- Oh, whoa, hold on.
I'm on the edge of my seat now
'cause you already covered
stopping and going.
And there's a third one?
- The third one is-
- But we'll get to the
third one right after this,
nope, psyche, here it is.
- While you're driving.
Now, you know this, 'cause we talked
about it a million times.
You get into a car with
like an Uber driver
and there are many Uber
drivers and drivers in general
who do this like pulsating
acceleration thing
where they're like (grunting).
It's like instead of just like treating,
you need to treat the
gas pedal and the brake
like I don't want to get sexual here.
- A lover. Go for it, man.
- It's like foreplay,
you know what I'm saying?
- Is this what you told Locke?
- I was like, you got,
I didn't use foreplay as an analogy.
I thought that would be inappropriate
but I'm using it here.
- Good.
- That's a fun, I mean, talk
about a fun driving lesson.
- "You want your foot to be on that brake
and you want it to ease."
And then I was like, "And
there's the art of the role
right when you sense that the
brakes are about to lock up,
you release, you release a little bit.
And this is of course, to
carry the foreplay thing,
right when you're about to-
- Uh-huh.
- You pull back.
Okay.
And so, and then when you take off,
you want to go, you
don't want to go straight
pedal to the metal, you want to ease.
And I said, "Picture it as-"
- Jenna, I didn't know
this is what he was gonna talk about
when I said, "Hey, you
should sit in on this one
because we're fully vaxxed."
- I said, "Picture it as if
you had a glass of wine,"
and I don't know why
I chose glass of wine, again.
- Oh, this is good.
- I said, "You've got a glass
of wine on the dashboard
and you want that to stay
perched on the dashboard.
That's how smooth do you
need to be at all times.
Because you're creating an experience
for the other passengers in your car."
- And then every time you
come to a smooth stop,
you want to take a deep gulp of that wine.
What?
- And so,
and then I said something like,
actually at one point I switched it to,
I said a glass of water.
He said, "You just said a
glass of wine a second ago."
(both laughing)
- He was with it.
- He's like totally on board.
- Oh, man.
- And like, you know
what? He's getting it.
So we've been driving
together and like he,
the thing is, is that Locke's
mind works a lot like mine,
and so instead of thinking
that what I was saying was ridiculous,
he understood that there was a standard
that we could hold ourselves to driving
that was above just getting around safely.
- That's profesora.
- Getting around with style
is what you're aspiring to.
- Now, if you want to, if you as the tutor
or the professor of driving school,
if you want to go full
Miyagi on this thing,
you need to bring a glass of wine.
- Yeah. I thought about this.
That's the ultimate test.
This is not, he's got his
driving test in a couple of weeks
and I'm gonna tell him
to take a glass of wine.
- Take a glass of wine.
(both laughing)
- He's like, my dad told me to bring this.
- That's good, man.
I mean, it's so funny because that's,
one of the first things
that I was teaching Lily
and that I've started
to instill in Lincoln is
this same principle of
like, as you're stopping
you got to picture the break-
- About to grip.
- It's like I try to
explain how the break works.
- You become the antilock brakes.
- Right, so that as it closes down,
as the brake pad closes down on it,
then at the last second you
want to release it a little bit.
- Right. Exactly.
- But I didn't use the,
I was very practical
and I think I missed the mark
with an inspirational analogy.
- Yeah. I don't think
you have to go foreplay.
I think the glass of wine
kind of covers everything.
- Mm-hmm.
- You put the glass of
wine on the dashboard.
You want it to stay filled.
You don't want it to spill
when you're stopping,
starting or anytime while going.
Taking a turn, all about smoothness.
- Yeah, you want to be
stopped before you realize it.
That's the surprise.
Oh, we're stopped.
- And let me tell you
right now-
- Oh, we're going again.
- Let me tell you, in the same way
that many people go their entire lives
without dealing with their own halitosis,
which it there's a certain
percentage of the population
that doesn't ever deal
with the halitosis, right?
There's a certain
percentage of the population
that never ascends to
the smooth driving level.
- This is our new, this is the second-
- This is our second mission in life.
- Yeah, it is.
- First mission is to get people to deal
with their nasty stank ass breath.
And the second one is to get
them to be smooth drivers.
- And let's us take the opportunity,
gargle with 50% hydrogen peroxide,
50% water,
or mix it with wine if
you're feeling freaky.
- You can put a glass of hydrogen peroxide
on your dashboard and do
both at the same time.
- Oh, yes! There it is!
- Yay! We just figured it out!
- We need to start the Rhett
Link driving school, man.
(Rhett laughing)
It's like-
- When you leave here, your
breath will smell like a,
I was gonna say these
bottom, but that's actually,
that's ridiculous.
- BYOHP.
BYOHP, man.
- Yeah. I like this.
Anyway. Locke's doing great.
His driving instructor told him,
now this is after a few lessons with dad.
Okay? The Mr. Miyagi of driving
as Link has just coined.
- I did not say that.
You fell short of that.
- The driving instructor
said, "You know what?
You're a natural."
And he said, "I got to tell
you a lot of these kids
that I teach are just dumb asses."
- That's what he said?
- And he was like, "But
you're a natural, in fact,"
he says, "You could pass
your test right now."
And he drove on the highway.
And then just the other day
for a Mother's Day brunch,
Jessie and I, I mean, the boys and I drove
to meet Jessie at a, she
was getting some time alone
for Mother's Day in a hotel
and we met her for a
brunch in West Hollywood.
So this is like a 40 minute drive.
And he drove, he had the
full LA driving experience,
driving on the 101, driving
over the canyon, Laurel Canyon.
Like I was like, and then
driving in West Hollywood
and the traffic wasn't
that bad on a Sunday,
but I was like, "Hey man,
you know, if you can drive here
you can drive anywhere
in the United States.
North Carolina would be a
breeze at this point for you."
So I think he's getting there.
- See, Christy was in the car,
we also went to West
Hollywood for Mother's Day.
- It's the place to be.
- But Christy was in the car so I did not,
it didn't even cross my mind
to suggest that Lily drive the car.
- Oh, 'cause Christy will get-
- A little anxious about it.
Yeah, and Lily will also get anxious.
You know, if like, this is our big,
we gotta make it to the brunch.
- I only yelled very loudly one time.
- What did you yell?
- It may have been a curse word.
I think it, "What the hell,"
like that kind of thing, you know?
But I think it was, he was doing great,
but then there was a car that
was stopped in the middle,
like a car that had broken down
in the middle of the 101 and
he got right up behind it
and he pulled in front of somebody
but then he moved over one more lane
and like really cut somebody off,
and I yelled at that point.
But then I immediately, let me say,
I immediately apologized.
- Okay. Okay.
- I was like, "Hey, I'm
sorry about yelling."
- Because crisis averted.
- And he was like, "Dad, I'm calm."
- Ooh.
Ooh.
- And I was like, you
know what? That's good.
- That had to hurt.
Master becomes the student.
- Yeah, well, I mean,
Daniel did win his match
at the end of "The Karate Kid."
- I wouldn't know.
When we, you know, to harken back
to when we did the college
visit, that was a long drive.
And I got Lily to drive some of the way
even though she did not want to.
- You got to get them on the freeway.
You got to have them merging.
You got to get merging.
That's what they're all scared of.
- Well, I've done that.
Like we did the whole, well,
let's go out and let's merge.
Let's take every off ramp and on ramp.
- Oh.
- Every off ramp and on ramp.
- That's called the Miyagi merge.
- Yeah, we did that.
- Because that's on and off, yep.
- I only wish there was wine involved.
- Merge on, merge off.
- Okay. That sounds familiar.
- This school.
- We got this man.
- Is Mr. Miyagi, is a
guy who played him dead?
Does that mean we have the rights?
- Yes.
- Is that how it works legally?
- Pat Morita.
- Pat Morita is dead.
- How do I know his name?
- I don't know, but you know what?
If you had given me like seven hours,
I could have arrive at that.
- Wow, I mean, I have
really impressed myself.
- You still haven't even seen
the original "Karate Kid"?
- Not all of it. I feel like I have.
- Pat Mortia.
- I watched the pilot of the,
I don't want to get off on that.
So I got Lily to drive
and we're on the freeway
and then we're like going,
we're going through some
hills off the freeway, okay?
And she's doing good, but
it was a little scary.
It's the first time we were all in the car
and she was driving and I want
her to get an idea of like-
- How was Lando doing with this?
- Longer distance driving. Well.
- Was he scareder than Christy?
- At one point he said,
"I don't feel good."
(Rhett laughing)
And then he said-
- I don't feel good.
- Few minutes later, he's
like, "I don't feel good."
You know how the I don't feel good
gets shorter and shorter, more staccato.
- Eventually it turns into, "I feel bad."
- And then-
- You transition.
- It turned into Christy's like,
"I think we need to pull over."
And then I'm like, "We
gotta find a good spot.
And Lily, I don't want you
to panic, but you know,"
we were going like 70 miles per hour
on kind of curvy roads, four lanes.
It was challenging.
I was like, okay, I see a spot.
"You're gonna pull over up there.
Lando, we're pulling over up there."
We hit the gravel and then the vomit
from the very back of the car
hits Christy's seat in
the middle of the car.
He threw up on her as we were
stopping and pulling out.
And you talk about dad yelling, I'm like,
"Just hold it in your mouth!"
- Oh, that's what he meant.
- "Just hold it in your mouth!"
- I didn't realize he was getting sick.
- He was getting sick.
- I thought he felt unsafe.
- No, he felt nauseous.
And he vomited in the car.
- And that's where the
smoothness comes in because-
- Then he got out.
- You make your passenger
sick if you don't take those,
and sometimes the roads
are, you can't avoid it.
- And when you're in the
very back, like the way back-
- It's even worse.
- And your a Neal, we get car sick.
- And that's what we teach
at the Miyagi school of
driving and fresh breath.
- Christy was trying,
so Christy hopped out.
It was like there was a
fire inside of the car.
It's like if you were watching
from across the street
at the fruit stand where
the guys were watching.
We pull over the, all the doors open.
We're trying to get Lando out.
Christy gets out of her seat
in the middle of the SUV.
And she yanks up on the thing
to make the seat fly forward.
- The eject button.
- Yeah, to make the seat fly forward
so that Lando can crawl
out from behind the seat.
And as she's doing that,
he's vomiting on the seat-
- Oh, he's vomiting again.
- I think that was the first vomit.
Like as we stopped, she hops out.
- Okay.
- He's vomiting on the seat.
He's gonna kill me for telling this story
but he's not gonna listen
and no one's gonna tell him.
- Right. Don't add him on Twitter.
- Christy's panicking so much
because I'm yelling for him
to "Hold it in your mouth!"
- Yeah. Like a good dad.
We don't accept that at the Miyagi school.
You cannot vomit in a car.
You are expelled.
- She ripped the handle that
makes the seat go forward.
She rips it off, it's in her hand
and then Lando has to
crawl across the seat
and get out and vomit some
more on the side of the road.
And I still don't know how fix it.
- How did you, how did you clean it up?
Did you have vomit smell
the rest of the ride?
- We had wipes.
The Neals got wipes, man.
Wipes for days.
- The McLaughlins would be in trouble.
We'd have like one napkin from McDonald's
in the glove compartment.
- So we blame that on Lily.
And then I took over from there
but I think it was-
- With the windows down.
- I think it would have been me.
It would've happened if
I was driving anyways
is what I'm trying to say.
- Right. It was the road.
Well, anyway, the kids are doing great.
(laughing)
- Listen, enough of their successes.
Let's get to our failures.
- But first let's talk about
the wonderful collection
of grooming items that we have
that all fit nicely into
a Mythical green bag.
- We care about what we look like.
I mean-
- Can you tell?
- I mean, just look at me today.
I mean, I look like,
I'm told, I look amazing
by friends, by my wife,
by strangers.
We developed everything in this sack
to make you look as good
as we think we look.
- Can you use the term bag?
- We got a Mythical brush.
This is, this is...
- It's like a wet/dry brush.
- Is this Jenna approved?
Yeah, it is.
- That's great for,
it works on my hair.
- Jenna approved.
- Works on Jenna's hair.
- Jenna has so much more hair than we do.
Mythical hand lotion,
Subtly Scented But Soothing.
- I don't use that, I
gotta be honest with you.
I'm not a lotion guy, but Link, boy,
he's covered in it.
- I love it.
I love the scent of it.
The Mythical number nine.
- When you teach in driving
sometimes putting lotion on your hands
makes it slippery on the wheel so.
- Clay pomade.
It's what I use in my hair.
- We don't do that in Miyagi school.
- That right there, I love
the smell of that too.
Smell of that.
- We've got a musical comb.
I mean, this thing as we've
already establish is incredible.
(comb music)
- That's fun.
We got some beard balm.
The pomade's not in here,
but you get the idea.
We got the beard oil.
And we've got the Peculiarly Perfect
Peanut Butter Peppermint Lip Balm
and the Candy Milk Lip Balm.
Get yours today at mythical.com.
I've got to put this stuff away.
Stall Rhett, say something.
- Oh, you know what I can tell you about?
I can remind you that
the first two episodes
of the scripted podcast
that we're starring in
called Ronstadt drop tomorrow.
Again-
- That's right.
- This is a scripted podcast.
This is a totally immersive world.
It's about a dude named Ronstadt
who is a 911 phone jockey
who answers all the weird
sort of supernatural calls.
He has a special ability
that gives him the ability
to maybe make some, to
exercise some decisions
based on the calls that he gets.
- And you know, all about Ronstadt
because you embodied the
role of Ronstadt in this.
And a lot of you have been asking us
as the trailer and stuff has come out
and now the episodes it's like,
"What was your inspiration
in creating this?"
Like, well, we didn't create Ronstadt.
We want to be clear about that.
QCODE brought the opportunity to us
and we got to know Johnny
and Brando who created it.
And they wrote the entire first season
so we had the benefit of
being able to read the plot
and the world that they've created,
and it really resonated with us.
There were a lot of like
Mythical esque elements
and just the world and
the tone and the fact
it was exciting for us to get involved.
So we'd love to say that we
created it, but we didn't.
We were brought on to the project later
and brought on as producers as well.
- And so that kind of helps answer
some of the questions
that people have had.
It was just like, "Well, usually
when you guys do something
like it's about two dudes
because you're two dudes and
this is not really like that.
Like Rhett's playing Ronstadt
and Link's playing like
three other roles."
- Yeah, it was, yeah.
And there was a moment that's like, okay,
is this for us?
But I think, you know,
because we were really
excited about the project
and doing something that
was getting our feet wet
in a different genre,
scripted audio podcasts,
like you get back into that
radio teleplay type stuff,
all of that's coming back around.
And maybe we'll create something
from the ground up later.
- Yeah, sure.
- But to get involved in that project
like we first heard about it in January.
I mean, if you were a part
of the Mythical Society AMA,
you already know this, but-
- Right.
- The pacing with which we
were able to just jump in
and get involved, kind of made
it, it made it a no brainer.
And it also gave me
the opportunity to say,
"You know what?
I can play a couple of
different roles here
and see where I fit in."
So you'll see where I fit
in as the season unfolds,
you just wait.
- So super immersive world
and the fact that all this can
happen just between your ears
and it's as big as your
imagination wants to make it.
It's just something that, it's a medium
we're excited to be involved with.
Ronstadt. First two
episodes drop tomorrow.
Wherever podcasts are found.
- Okay, before we get into
creative failure and rejection,
I just wanted to start off with like
some relational rejection.
Have you ever, Rhett been
relationally rejected?
- Of course not.
(Link laughing)
- I know you'd set your sights on a girl,
but that didn't necessarily mean
that their sights were set on you.
- You know, I've actually, I've
thought about this recently.
I actually had a tendency,
well, I think there's two things going on.
First of all, I just really like women
(laughing)
and that started very early
and it was very intense,
like from well, I'm not talking,
this was like not at puberty.
This was before puberty.
This was like first grade. Right?
I just I had infatuation issues
and I would kind of get focused on a girl.
And typically
I would focus on someone who-
- You dream about flying to her house.
- Well, I would focus on girls
that were for lack of a better
word, unattainable for me.
Right? Like I don't know what it was.
It would be like, okay,
this girl is two years older than me.
- Mm-hmm.
- And it would be embarrassing
for her to date me.
Even if we were in the same grade,
she probably wouldn't date me, right?
I mean, you've seen
pictures of me growing up.
And so I was a little bit gangly
but I had a lot of confidence and I would,
and once I kind of made that decision,
I would begin what I guess
my was my version of flirting
and talking and telling other
people that I like this girl,
telling her friends that I like them.
- Moving and shaking, trying
to get something going.
- And there were a couple of times
where this was a successful strategy
and that was all I needed
to continue doing it.
But I would say that just
the percentage breakdown,
it's probably 80, 20, 80%
rejection, 20% success.
So rejected more often
than I was accepted.
- So, I didn't think it
was that much of a spread.
Sorry to use the term.
- I mean...
- So does that mean that no
one rejection stands out?
- Well, I mean, if you're talking about
my biggest crush in high school,
I don't even consider that a rejection
because it was so unrealistic.
But like, there were, I remember a girl-
- But like do you like, one
where you were like to her face
saying, "Will you be my girlfriend?"
Or "Will you go with me" or
"Will you go out on a date?"
And she was like, "Ah, no.
- I don't think, well, you know it was
in like middle school, high school.
It never really got to the point
where you were face to face
asking and being rejected.
The rejection usually
came through a friend
before you got there.
- That helps. Right.
- Yeah and I mean, the funny thing is
is I don't ever remember,
again, it's hard to
remember exactly emotionally
what was going on in high school.
But I would kind of just
be like, okay. All right.
That's not happening.
So I would just kind of move on.
- So you never, like, it never shook you
that you can recall?
- No.
- Hmm.Okay.
Because for me, I mean, my
problem was the opposite.
Like I never got, I was
so anxious and self-aware
and just kind of felt like
I didn't know what I wanted.
And it was so much about
what should I be doing
so that I can, you know,
fit in or whatever.
So like girls would, I would
hear through the grapevine
that some girl wanted to date me.
And then I was like, "Oh
crap, this is a huge test.
I feel like I'm gonna fail."
There was a lot of fear and
anxiety that short circuited,
it was just like the polar
opposite of you at that time.
You know, it short-circuited
so many of these experiences.
So for me to say, well, you know what?
I don't think I was ever rejected
is definitely not a brag at all,
and I think this is something
that when we talk about
the creative ramifications
of rejection and failure
it's this dynamic of fear kind
of keeping you from action.
And if you overcome that
whether that's to create
or initiate with somebody
or try to initiate
some sort of a relationship,
you never know what can
happen if you go for it
but you know what's gonna
happen if you don't, nothing.
- Right.
- And, I think for me,
the only rejection was,
I mean, definitely I was dumped by Jana.
- Yeah.
- My sophomore year.
She was a freshmen.
And she wrote me a note
and I put it in my, yeah.
She wrote me the note
that we were breaking up
because I was just a friend to her
because I clammed up so much around her.
And I was so anxious and in my own head.
And it was about what
should I be doing and not
what do I want to do?
I was so in my own head
and she was very nice
and she let me off the hook, but it was a,
I mean, I remember reading
that letter and boy,
it was embarrassing to be like, okay,
you're a great person.
I read the letter on
Good Mythical Morning,
because once we moved to LA, I found my,
I brought my soccer bag
out here for some reason,
- Yeah, got to keep your soccer bag.
- I thought I was gonna play some soccer
after not playing for like
a decade or something.
It was sentimental value to have my cleats
and stuff in there.
But I found that I had
kept that rejection letter.
I guess, I don't know why I did it.
I'd like to think it
was some sort of lesson
that then I was gonna
go after what I wanted
from then forward and I wasn't
gonna let fear clam me up,
but I don't think that
was actually the case.
I just think it was just
like, man, this hurts.
I'm so sentimental.
I'm gonna shove it in
this bag and I'm never,
maybe I didn't go in that pocket anymore
and maybe it was just sentimental.
- I was giving you good
advice at the time, man.
I was like this is quite an opportunity
that you've been given.
Because she like invited you to her house.
- I went to her house.
- And I was like, "Well,
you should definitely
accept that invitation."
- Yeah, one of my biggest regrets
is not riding the four-wheeler with her.
- Right, yeah, and that's not a euphemism,
that's literally riding a four-wheeler.
We were in North Carolina.
- But I mean, it would
have been so awesome.
I mean, here I am, you know,
about to turn 43 years old
and I'm still regretting
not straddling her
on that four-wheeler.
- Right, yeah.
- I mean, we both be facing the same,
I don't know, who knows what directions
we would have been facing.
- There's lots of things.
The seat is very, very wide.
- We could have been
facing every direction, man.
- The seat is very wide and long.
- I mean, once I got away from her-
- There's probably a whole like section
on some porn website of just
stuff that happens on ATVs.
I'm not saying I know about it.
I'm just saying that that's
how specialized things can get.
- Now, you gotta wield the
power that we have with caution,
because just saying that
is gonna like spike that search.
- What if it generates a
whole new category of porn?
I mean, we can take credit for that too.
The Miyagi school of driving,
fresh breath and ATV porn
(both laughing)
- Okay, so we're teaching people
how to have sex on an ATV.
- There's a bunch of ATVs there.
Are those for driving?
No, that's just for sex.
(both laughing)
- Oh, man.
- Okay.
- That rejection hurt.
So I guess, I mean,
that's all we have to go
into the relational stuff,
but just get back to the creative stuff,
let's get in our minds
what we feel like is not
rejection, but failure.
What's our like biggest creative failure?
Do you have something in your mind?
I have something in my mind.
- I mean, the first thing
that comes to mind is GMM 22.
- Yeah, that's my answer.
And we've, I mean, we devoted
a whole episode at the time.
It would be interesting to
go back and listen to that.
- Oh, I'm not gonna go
back and listen to that,
- I don't want to do that.
You can do that, because it was like-
- That was one of my, I am not proud of,
I'm not, but we can talk about that
because I think that's a good example
of the way that failure and rejection
can kind of get into your head, you know,
because I got very, well,
just a little background.
- Categorize what it was.
- So what year was that?
2017?
- I don't know.
- 2018? 2018.
- 17 and 18 she says.
- 17 and 18. Okay.
So we were given the opportunity,
we were approached by YouTube.
They were investing in
different kinds of content.
They actually originally came to us,
I don't know if we've ever
talked about this part of it,
but they originally came to us
and asked us if we would make like
a late show version of
Good Mythical Morning.
So like a Good Mythical
Night or something like that.
And we were like, that
sounds like a great idea
but like "We're already kind of really
doing all we can with
Good Mythical Morning."
And we're like, "Is
there some way to expand
Good Mythical Morning itself?"
Which going back in time, it kind of feels
like we should have just
done the late show version.
But anyway, in addition to GMM,
because we ended up doing
five parts of a show
every single day.
I think it went down to four, but anyway,
it was like a multi-part thing and-
- The technology worked against us,
but also, you know,
we said, yes, we wanted to go for it.
And it did not work.
I mean, long story short, it didn't work.
And it hurts when it's,
you know, if you create something
and you put your heart and soul into it,
I'm saying this by contrast,
I'm not describing what we did with that.
But as an artist if you create something
that you pour your heart and soul into,
and then nobody sees it or cares about it,
that's a certain type of failure.
- It's a different thing.
- What we experienced was something
that was near and dear to
so many Mythical Beasts
that they cared about so much.
And we messed with it in
a way that frustrated them
and was not a good experience
which then made it an even more
difficult experience for us,
because we were trying
to take into account
all of the feed, there
were so much feedback.
- Yeah.
- So that was a certain type
of very scrutinized failure.
It's kind of like the "Waterworld,"
like big budget movie scenario
where everybody's geared up to see it
and then it's just horrible.
So it becomes the object lesson of
cinema no-nos.
And because there was,
the digital space is
much more experimental
and frontier-like,
I don't think it serves,
and no one's emulating GMM to the point
where it becomes a cautionary tale.
So I don't know exactly what we learned,
but I think I'm sure we
learned a lot of stuff.
- Well and we both agree that
we're very glad that we
said yes and we tried it.
I mean, 'cause there are number of things
that came from that.
It honestly, it transformed our business.
Right?
- Right.
- We ended up moving
into the space next door,
and we ended up more
than doubling our staff.
- The funding that we had,
we put to work in ways
that we're still seeing
those benefits now.
- We were able to take so many
of the things that we learned
just from a creative and
a production standpoint,
and then incorporate it back into GMM
when we went back to the
one episode a day version.
- So, I totally take back what I said.
It's like I don't know
if we learned anything.
- No.
- Because I think the point,
the principle is absolutely we learned
a whole bunch of stuff and
that's kind of the point
and it kind of redeems
the experience, right?
If that didn't work
but it changed the trajectory
of where we're headed
and I can't even articulate
all the lessons that we learned
but they're ingrained in our experience
and impact the decisions
that we have been making
ever since then.
And I think that's a principle of failure
is it's less of a failure
if you went for something,
tried something and learned from it,
than not going for anything
and learning nothing
and you might've saved face a little bit,
but I mean, if it would have
destroyed Good Mythical Morning
and it wouldn't have recovered.
- Then we would maybe
be thinking differently.
- I mean, that could happen,
businesses go bankrupt,
people try things, they have bad ideas.
Or they have good ideas that just,
things out of their control tank it.
That absolutely could have happened for us
and then it would have been a regret
and it would have been
what we call a mistake-
- But even then-
- But a creative failure-
- I choose to believe that even then
it would have led to something else
because that's just my experience
is that always there's a lesson.
Thankfully the lesson didn't
come along with a complete
fumbling of Good Mythical
Morning and killing it.
It came back.
But there's always a lesson and you know,
and I'm especially grateful for it
because that's why I
started going to therapy.
And because of just how
difficult that time was,
not just the rejection, the
rejection was difficult,
but it was more just, it
was too much to take on.
But you know, the reason I
don't want to go back and listen
to that episode
where we like essentially
complained and defended ourselves,
and I did it more than you
did so I take credit for that.
I was defensive.
I was in a bad place.
I was hurt.
I was trying to, I said
some things I regret.
Now,
I think that my, if that
were to happen today,
post-therapy, my processing
of what was going on
would be very different.
Because one of the things,
and is it next week
that we're gonna start
talking about the Enneagram?
- Yes. We're gonna do it.
- So we are gonna start,
so stay tuned next week
and maybe even the following week,
we may do a two-part
thing with the Enneagram
where we're gonna talk
about what the Enneagram is
a little bit, but more just talk about
our experience with
it, what numbers we are
and how that has impacted our lives.
But I am
Enneagram three, I'm a performer.
And there's a number of things
that might go into that,
meaning that,
it's part nature, part nurture
that I have been a very
performance minded person.
And when you're a person
who finds their worth
in their success,
you might also be a person
who finds their worthlessness
in their failure.
- Their failure.
- And so I think that there is and again,
and I have been,
you know, things have
gone really well for me.
You know what I saying?
Things have gone really well for us.
Things have also gone
well for me individually.
Before we ever started doing what we did,
it was just like I kind of prided myself
on being good at stuff, right?
It's like okay, I'm
gonna make good grades.
I'm gonna be good at basketball.
I mean, the things that I choose to do,
I'm gonna do them well, right?
And,
so I kind of developed this sense of self
that was based on being good at things.
And then when it keeps
happening, when you keep trying
and of course, there's lots of
failures, there's rejections
like those relational, I
wouldn't say that dating
was one of the things I was good at
so I'll just put that out there.
I did really well one time with my wife
and things have worked out
really well since then.
But this idea, I think the
thing that was so difficult
about GMM 22, it was because
such a public failure
so many people saw it as
you guys tried something
and it did not work and it's
so obvious to everybody.
Why don't you just admit now-
- Isn't that embarrassing?
- Yeah.
And again, there's this
you start, if you're me,
you start, you've placed some
of your own personal value
in the way that what
you've created is received.
Right?
And so I told you last week,
my recommendation was Elizabeth
Gilbert's "Big Magic,"
which I was talking to
my therapist about that
and he was like, "Oh, you know,
I used to recommend to a
lot of people her TED Talk."
which if you don't want to read the book,
which I do recommend the book,
you can kind of get a
lot of the same ideas,
and she's actually done a number
of really popular TED Talks,
where she talks about this.
But she kind of emphasizes this idea
of what you create matters a whole lot
but also doesn't matter at all, right?
There's this sort of built-in irony
like it's sacred and it's awesome
and creative creative expression
is an incredible thing,
but also you kind of have to
live as if it doesn't matter,
especially how it's received.
The thing that you can't control.
The thing you can control
is what you create
and how you create it.
The thing you cannot
control is this reception.
And we operate in this world where
reception is such a big piece of the pie
because we throw things
out there constantly.
We're throwing things out there to this,
the most interactive media
genre that's ever existed.
You know, what has happened
since YouTube, right?
So immediate feedback, and
also this high quantity
of content that's going out there.
So you're just getting
this constant feedback
that shaping everything.
And so that's been very difficult for me,
a performance-based person,
to create in a medium
where approval,
literally like how many people like this,
how many people watch it,
the approval is quantifiable.
- And it's a reflection in your mind
of what people think of you,
their assessment of you as a person.
Oh, you must not be as
smart as I thought you were,
Rhett and Link, because
you made a decision
that led to something
that was embarrassing.
- Right.
- That was a failure.
You know, I think the
thing for us though is
because we have this longstanding
and growing relationship
with our audience,
that it created a soft
place for us to fall.
You know, where...
I think any anybody who
listens to this podcast weekly
has a sense of who we are and is on board.
We have a, you know,
there's an understanding
and there's a belief in, "Hey,
I might, I like these guys,
you know, I'm loyal to these guys."
- If you stick around.
- Even if some things that they create
aren't the best thing for me.
Like, you may have a favorite artist
who has a body of work
that from album to album,
and you may not like every
single album the same,
like Sturgill Simpson.
Like I feel I have a
relationship with his work,
not with him that is, you know,
it's special to me
but there are certain albums
that like I really applaud the fact
that he's doing his thing
and it wasn't for me.
And there's been a few
of those albums. Right?
But I still,
I still believe in him and like give him,
and those weren't failures.
They just weren't for me.
But even if they were failures,
I'm like, "Hey, you know, I'm still a fan
and I respect the fact that
just because I don't like it,
or even if people didn't like it,
that he was doing his thing
and I'm on board for that."
And we have the benefit
of having that soft place to fall
because we have that loyalty
and that relationship built.
There's, you know,
I was reading Questlove's creativity book,
which spoiler alert,
I'll recommend at the end
and give you details about it.
But he's talking about, he
talked about a creative failure
and the type of failure
that like if you put
something out into a world
and nobody notices or cares,
and he was spinning that
in a positive way as
there's freedom in that.
There's freedom in that to do something,
there's freedom that we don't have
because everything we do
because of our success
has a level of scrutiny that
if you're a developing artist
and you do something that doesn't work,
you can focus on the freedom
to then try something new
and not be under the thumb
of people's expectations.
I think there's a way
to redeem every failure
or every rejection.
And I definitely think that's,
finding, there's always,
you can always see it as an
opportunity if you want to,
you can always spin and
focus on the positive
and you can learn things from it.
You know, if it builds into who you are
and changes who you are,
then it was worth it.
Right?
And it enables you to move forward
as you don't allow it to
keep you from moving forward.
And I definitely feel that if we,
yeah, as we talk about GMM 22 now
and if we continue to talk
about it and we're not,
'cause I'm just not that interested in it.
But I'm interested in talking about
some other failures and rejections,
our conversation would
continue to be different.
Like so all the stuff that you said,
and that I would say if we were
continuing to talk about it,
will be different than what we were saying
at that point in time
and we were still really reeling from it.
You know?
And that may be the biggest takeaway,
that the experience made us,
maybe maturity's the right word or-
- Well, we had the, you know,
we have the benefit of
being able to kind of
get back on the horse
and throw something
else out into the world.
It's kind of what you're
saying, a soft place to land.
You've got an audience.
It's not like when we
made a television show
that got one season, which we can talk,
our two TV things, both our
very first foray in 2007
as hosts, that show was short-lived.
And then the show that
we actually helped make
and create that was much more about us,
got one season.
- Commercial Kings.
- And then it's like you
can't just turn around
and churn out another television show,
but you can turn to the internet
and turn to a faithful audience
so we do have this ability to kind of,
we have this distinct advantage
of not having to sort of sit
in our failure and not be able
to move forward creatively.
And one of the things that
Elizabeth Gilbert talks about
and this just may be in a book,
but it's definitely one of the TED Talks,
but she talks about how, you know,
she had the incredible success
of writing "Eat, Pray, Love"
which got turned into a movie.
I haven't read the book or seen the movie.
I don't necessarily plan
to, I'm not sure it's for me
but it was a huge success.
It was on a bestseller
list for like three years.
And then she experienced
this incredible success
and then there was all this pressure
on writing her next book,
and she wrote her next book and it bombed.
And she was like "Thank goodness.
I got that out of the way."
Unlike Harper Lee who she
talks about in "Big Magic,"
who wrote "To Kill a Mockingbird"
and then didn't write anything else.
And she didn't write anything
else, because she was scared
of not being able to repeat the success
of "To Kill a Mockingbird".
- I thought there was
a hidden novel though.
- No, she did, something
else was released later
but I'm saying for a long
time, she didn't write.
- Yeah, but it wasn't,
Harper Lee did not publish it
I don't think.
- Right. She was so scared.
So one of the things that she talks about
is how you've got this
home position, right?
And then success throws you away from home
and failure throws you away from home,
but emotionally you don't really
have the cognitive ability
to feel the difference.
In other words, success
can be just as disorienting
as failure can, right?
And it also, it goes to your
head in a similar way, right?
So success can breed fear,
failure can breed fear.
And she's like whether
you are super successful
with something or it's
something is a huge flop,
the goal for her is to return home,
is to return to home base.
And for her home is doing the thing
that she would do anyway,
if success or failure,
you know, whether people
are watching or not
and that's writing for her, right.
It's simple for her.
She's gonna go back to writing
and that's what she's gonna do
whether or not you're buying it or not.
And I think that now, our
creative process is complicated.
It's not, we're not just writing
we're doing a bunch of different things.
And also the larger, the more
success that we've gotten
and the bigger our company has become,
there's more people depending on the stuff
that we come up with working
than there were 10 years ago.
Right?
So now it's like, okay, now we've got,
there's people's livelihoods
are on the line, right?
There's a company, there's employees.
And so something working
isn't just about us
and our like personal
creative fulfillment.
So it's a little bit complicated,
but the advantage we have
with being able to turn around
and just be like, well,
there's gonna be another video on Monday.
There's gonna be another
podcast next week.
There's gonna be another,
we're gonna right back
to the drawing board
and start writing another
pilot for something
or writing a movie, is that
our home is pretty clear.
We always know where to come back to
and that's just coming back
to the creative process
and just churn something else out.
- But specifically, Good Mythical Morning
and Ear Biscuits being kind
of like a creative home base
where it's properties that are working,
where we're reaching you
listening or watching.
You know?
It's quite a luxury, especially because
we've been able to structure
our professional lives
to then spend a good amount
of time on speculative stuff.
And I do want to get back to
that and reference the stuff
we talked about last week,
everything that fizzled
out was rejected or failed.
You know, it's difficult for
me because I'm more of an,
you know, I thrive more
in the execution phase
and I don't mean the killing,
but I'm meaning carrying
out of the creative process
then in the ideation
and the writing of it,
which is a point that you thrive in.
So I'm actually curious
how you interact with,
you know, a premature rejection.
Like we write a pitch,
we write five pitches on a
page like we read last week,
and then, you know,
maybe none of them,
nobody's excited about it.
So then we all say, "Oh crap.
We'll just put that in a Google Drive
and read it on Ear Biscuits
years later and laugh about it."
But in the moment it's like, ah,
gotta start over.
Already starting over.
And I'm sitting on my
hands like, oh, okay.
Gotta start over.
You know, or we are writing,
we decide to go write a pilot
and spend that amount of time
to invest in that, knowing that
because it's a foray into
traditional entertainment,
it's skipping tracks for us.
And we have this, you know,
it's something that we really want.
We want to,
we want to stretch our arms
and to build our muscles creatively
and take some swings in other places
just to to get those type of
things out into the world,
just to make that type of stuff,
to have that challenge and that
experience and that reward.
But we know that
we're not as special.
In fact, what we discover is that,
I guess in most people's
ideas and these gatekeepers,
like the things that make us special
or at least the popularity,
and the momentum that we have.
(clears throat)
Excuse me.
And the success that we have.
- Not an asset.
- It just doesn't seem,
it gets us in the room
but it doesn't necessarily
get things made.
- And I would go as far as to say
it's not an asset, it's a liability.
- Hmm. Yeah.
I mean, we at least start to question that
because it's like, okay,
we can get in the room, but is it, okay,
are our ideas and what we've written
and what our pitch is,
are they not good enough?
Well, there's other reasons
that don't have anything
to do with who we are
and like our ability
and talent as artists,
but it is a part of it.
So it's like, you start,
you can get in your own head
about that type of stuff.
Because you pitch in the
room and they're like,
there's a million reasons to say no
and there seems to only be
a few reasons to say yes.
And then even a yes to a pilot is some,
it's an unknown length process to then,
and it's a crap shoot that
something ever gets made.
So it's like, it's setting
us up for a beating
and so even though we're so successful,
we focus on what we want to go after.
And we do have this experience
of taking a beating,
you know?
So how do we deal with that?
And 'cause we keep signing up for it
and it's more frustrating for us
because we know the
experience of making something
and have it and people seeing it
and people liking it, you know?
Or if they don't, it's
a soft place to fall.
We're spoiled. Right?
But we're trying to switch tracks
and do something different.
I mean,
so I'll let you respond to that
and then I'll talk about how
like I've tried to adjust
my approach mentally
to this entire process.
- I mean, I'm thinking a lot of things.
You know, I definitely,
there is a part of me that
I've always kind of had this belief
that's not a realistic belief
that we can do anything.
Right? (laughing)
That if we-
- It's kind of like you can date anybody.
- Yeah, if you set your mind to something,
we can figure this out.
We can write a book.
We can write a movie.
We can make music.
We can, you know, and so we
have done a lot of those things
because there's just
this persistent belief
that we can do it.
'Cause I'm always like, well,
somebody figured it out, you know?
And the funny thing is
that in "Big Magic,"
she kind of talks...
One of the things I always think that,
when I'm writing for instance
and I'm learning a lot while I'm writing
and especially if we have the privilege
of working with someone
who's more experienced
like we did on a recent
thing that we developed
that's still kind of
maybe gonna be something
but probably not. (laughing)
Is my lack of experience and
education in the creative arts
becomes frustrating to me, right?
Now, meaning that I went to
engineering school, right?
I didn't even pay attention
in any of my creative classes.
I didn't make the connection
between how there was an opportunity
to pursue vocationally entertainment
until YouTube came around.
And so you start seeing
that like, okay, well,
it isn't easy to just write something.
It doesn't just come naturally.
Like there are sort of,
there are some unspoken rules
and there are rules that the people
who are gonna be reading your scripts,
no, they've been educated.
They've read a lot of scripts.
There's certain things
that they're looking for.
Now, I'm not, you can get way
too formulaic in the process.
But one of the things that
she talks about in "Big Magic"
is how that creative
education and academia
is kind of overrated, right?
Like the idea of storytelling
in general is something
that is exists in our DNA
as a species, and that this is who we are.
And then I start questioning, well,
do I have anything important to say?
Do we have something that
people will care about?
Is this original enough?
You know, is this an original idea?
Elizabeth says, you know,
"Originality is secondary
to authenticity," right?
And there's nothing, ultimately
there's nothing original.
Like there's nothing new
under the sun, you know?
Solomon had that figured out.
And so you're going to do
something that has been done.
You're gonna come up with a melody
that kind of already exists.
It's like there's only so
many combinations of notes.
There's only so many expressions of ideas.
There's only so many stories you can tell,
but only you as an individual
can tell your specific story
in your specific way.
And so I, so that-
- So this whole counteract
an inferiority complex
or a fear of being exposed as
like uneducated or untalented.
- 'Cause everyone is faking it.
When you think about it,
the person that you're
pitching to is also faking it.
They're trying to maintain their job.
They don't want to get fired
and they want to please the
person that they report to
who wants to please the
who wants to be the man
or whatever, you know?
So it's like, everyone is kind,
I'm not saying that technical
creative writing education
is a bad thing.
I think that would be great.
I wish I had had had it honestly, right?
Especially given what I'm doing now
but when you kind of just are like listen,
this doesn't really matter.
And also if I'm not enjoying
every step of the process
up to the point of rejection,
which the good news is
I am, I enjoy writing.
I enjoy the process of it creating a role
or exploring things
and putting words into characters mouths
and that kind of thing.
And every single time I do
it, I learn a whole lot.
So I know the next time I
do it, it's gonna be better.
And I'm probably gonna increase,
the chances will be
increased the next time
that this will come to light.
But you know, what? If it
doesn't, it's just a lesson.
It's just an experience.
And it's what was supposed to happen.
You know, even if that's not true,
even if everything doesn't
happen for a reason,
living like everything
happens for a reason
is a healthy perspective.
- I think for me,
and this is something that I actually
started saying out loud
as we were entering
into certain processes.
I'm thinking of two examples.
One is
we were doing a pitch and we
had teamed up with somebody
who if the pitch went
as a television show,
they will be running the,
they'd be the head writer
and like show runner.
And we were pitching that.
And then the other one
is writing the pilot
that we collaborated
with a friend and mentor.
- Yeah.
- So with the first one, I
remember we were going into a,
well, it doesn't matter
which network, but you know,
a bonafide meeting, big deal.
By the way,
our livelihood is not
connected to our pitches
working for things being bought from us.
Like we have this luxury
of not having this,
oh gosh, I gotta, you know, this
I gotta put food on the table.
You know, we gotta make this work.
- There's not a desperation.
- There's not desperation,
but we want it so bad that it feels
the same at times.
- Yeah.
- And I do think that
as you were getting at,
that can short circuit
your ability to pitch and
sell something I think
when it's like you're gripping so tightly
that you're like shaking or, you know?
Sometimes literally.
I remember we had done it,
we had gone around town
pitching this thing and
this the last person
we were pitching to.
And remember, we were
sitting in the waiting room
with the writer who we
paired ourselves with.
And before we went back there,
you remember I said to him,
I was like, "Well,
you know what, this is our last meeting.
If this doesn't go, we
may never see you again."
(Rhett laughing)
You know, we were introduced
to him for this project.
We really hit it off.
I think I could see us
being really good friends
and collaborators
and having an entire
creative future together,
and that's one of the
reasons we picked the person.
- Mm-hmm.
- Or this could be the last time
that we ever see each other.
And there was like this kind
of uncomfortable laughter
because we all knew it was true.
Right?
It's just not the type of
thing that you typically say
unless your Link and
you're a little nervous
or you're trying to figure
out something to talk about.
And there's nothing like
a good dose of the truth
to really shake you out of being nervous.
And that's exactly what happened.
That was over a year ago.
And even without the COVID of it all,
like we still would have
never seen him again.
I mean, we might, who knows
if we'll ever cross paths
but there's just like, you know,
we could be working together for years
or we could never see each other.
Isn't that funny?
- Yeah. And it's true.
- And the reason why I said it is
because I was trying to
adopt this philosophy
that like all of this stuff is so tenuous.
Like
the least we can do is be
entertained by the process
because it may not be ever
anything more than this.
Like we go into this
pitch, we practiced it.
We kind of know it backwards and forwards.
Let's have fun with it.
If all that happens with this project
and it never goes past a pitch,
I want to have fond
memories of this pitch,
like I want to take the pressure off
and just convey that we believe in it
and leave the results to whatever power
you want to leave the results to.
So that's the thing
that I was trying to do
was just embrace the process
because the results
are out of our control.
- Yeah, all we can do is we
can come up with an idea,
we can write a story and we
can have a compelling pitch
but it is so tenuous because the reason
that someone might say no
could very easily be
what they had for lunch.
It could be a conversation that they had
with their spouse right
before the meeting.
- And that can be
frustrating or it can be fuel
to let go of the things
that you just have an illusion of control.
- I think when you actually think about it
and when you understand how tenuous it is,
for me, it is helpful to
be like you know what?
Why would I place my value,
my happiness in the hands of someone
who just had a bad lunch?
(laughing)
You know what I'm saying? Like what?
And so again, it is frustrating
when you take the, but I feel like for me
step one is finding joy in the process,
what you just said and that is everything
from the conceptualization and the writing
to going out and talking about it,
meeting people, doing the pitches,
having fun while we're doing it.
And then the second thing
is, and this is not easy,
I want to be very clear.
This isn't easy for anybody.
It's definitely not easy for me,
somebody who built an identity on
impressing people .
To take all the power,
to give the results,
my expectations, there's no power in that.
I'm just removing all my
expectations altogether
and trying to detach
myself from the outcome.
If I can enjoy the process
and detach myself from the outcome,
and again, there's things
that make that easier for us
given the fact that it
doesn't have to work.
Like we can go back, we can
keep doing what we're doing.
It's we're gonna be okay
in the short term financially, you kno?w
We're not depending on this
working in order to eat.
- Yeah.
- So those are the, and again,
and if that's your situation, again,
I know I'm biting a lot of
Elizabeth Gilbert's thoughts here
but I mean, she kind of makes the point
that because the process,
the arts are so tenuous
and because people,
you're putting your
livelihood into the whims
of another person who
holds the purse strings,
she recommends don't quit your day job.
I know that sounds harsh,
but she's like she didn't
stop working her day job
until after she published,
"Eat, Pray, Love"
and it started seeming
like it was working.
Like she had all these different jobs
and she was like make yourself,
give yourself that creative time,
but the moment that you
begin to attach yourself
and attach your self worth
and attach your own livelihood to it,
it becomes a different thing.
Now we had the privilege of, okay, well,
the baseline creativity stuff is working.
So we have this privilege of
being able to kind of do that,
to put these things out into the world
and not have them have to work.
- Yeah and with that second example of
co-writing a pilot was with somebody
with a lot more experience
that can give, you know,
just being on Zoom calls
and having that time
it was just like, you know, this is just,
the thing that I would remind myself
and just I would say out loud at times
to all of us on the
Zoom call is just like,
you know, like you said,
this may never be anything,
but it's fun to think
about what it could be.
And this is fun right now.
Like this experience is fun.
Like taking that moment
to pause and recognize,
oh, we just got notes,
but the way he gives notes
is he records it all,
audio stream of consciousness
and then he just emails it to you
so like you've got this
like verbal processing
of what we've conceptualized
and what you've written.
And there's like this
detailed analysis of it
that like people would pay,
people would save up for years
to get that type of feedback
on something they've
written from someone of
this level of experience.
And just saying, okay,
the notes might eviscerate.
And they didn't,
but even if they did, it's like, wow,
what a cool process.
It's like signing up
for your driving course
and then you get to the parking lot
and Mr. Miyagi gets in the car with you
with a glass of wine.
It's like, oh God, this is freaking cool.
I need to go home and
watch "Karate Kid" now
and I think I would really,
really appreciate this.
- Yeah.
- You know what I'm saying?
- And it's tough do that.
It's tough to enjoy the process
because I think there is a,
there's this romantic notion
of the starving artist
and the desperate artist
and the tortured artist,
you know, literally,
somebody like Van Gogh
cutting off his own ear, you know?
Like you have this, there's
this just cultural entity,
which is
you've got to drag yourself through
a torturous experience
in order to come out
on the other side in success.
And it's like, well, first of all,
the success on the other side
may be just as disorienting
as the failure and the struggle.
You are who you are
and your baseline happiness
is kind of pre tuned.
You know what I'm saying?
So it's very difficult for me
'cause I always have thought that,
yeah, this is supposed to be this like,
this is supposed to be a grind
and you're really supposed
to just like throw yourself
in this and be able to look
back and be like, aw, man
we worked so hard on that
and then it became a thing,
but it's just like, I don't know
if it's gonna become a thing.
Can I just learn to enjoy the steps?
I mean, who know?
If one of these things becomes
a reality, it'll be fun.
It'll be awesome.
But it'll also complicate our
lives in a certain way, right?
Like, okay, we do 100
different things already.
Let's throw 101 in there
and this one will be
making a television show,
making a movie?
I'm not saying we won't
find a way to make it happen
but you know what?
It'll be stressful.
It'll be a complicating factor in things.
- Yeah.
- So it's not always
like the success or something happening
is gonna some incredible thing
that is gonna change your life, you know?
Yeah.
So I think
ultimately for me it's
just a constant battle
to detach myself from the outcome
and also when the outcome is failure,
which is most often,
especially with the
stuff that we're talking,
it's in fact only almost
exclusively failure and rejection
with the ideas that we've
talked about before.
Seeing that there's probably
ultimately more longterm value
in those rejections and failures
than there would be in
one of them working out.
- And I think my chief
struggle is something that
will make more sense in light
of our Enneagram conversations
over the next couple of weeks
because my struggle is when
things are so speculative
and they're not actually
like nuts and bolts of doing
and like perfecting,
like execute and then perfecting,
like the next parts of
the creative process.
Like if a project never
gets off the ground
and that keeps happening and
happening, I get very dejected.
I feel like I'm sitting
on my hands, you know?
Because I'm not the writer.
And you know, I'm not as much of the idea,
from nothing comes an idea.
It's more of like, yes,
I get on board with those things
and then let's go for it.
- Right.
- You know?
So there's a different
type of struggle for me
in this kind of like, to stay engaged
when it's, you know, our hands
have been tied with COVID
but also so much is speculative.
And now we're, you know,
we've actually got people
whose full-time job
as a development person.
I don't think I could ever
be a development person
because now that we're working closely
with Mallory and Taylor
who are like working for us
full-time to take our ideas,
develop other ideas, bring projects in
and like get traditional
things off the ground.
It's like, it's very hard
for me to remain engaged
because it's just so speculative.
I can just be like this
is never gonna happen.
I'm never gonna be able to
engage what I feel like my gifts
and my passions are because we're just
meandering around a starting line
and then no one may ever
fire the gun to run.
You know?
It's like call me when
it's time to run, you know?
And so it's been,
that's what's been difficult
for me and it's not even,
so then I start to
anticipate the rejection
and just disengage, I
think to protect myself
from the dejection of
never getting to the part
that's where I feel like
I thrive and I can find my flow.
- Right.
- And maybe that'll come up more
or you can just kind of
take what I just said
and map it on to being an
Enneagram one next week so.
- And I think that's one of
the reasons that we end up,
you know, we've got something planned.
We have a creative exercise.
- Yeah, we do.
- That we have planned
for the fall that is-
- We have complete control over it.
And it is going to happen.
We're going to make it.
- Yeah and I think for me,
that was a reaction to
you're talking about.
Yeah, sure, I may be engaged
in like the writing process,
but when for years
you've been able to put things out there,
whether it was a music video
or a sketch with something
that's coming from a different
place creatively than,
obviously, Good Mythical
Morning is its own entity,
but Good Mythical Morning has become,
as we've established,
it's become an environment
that we place ourselves into
and we're just kind of
operating off the cuff
and as ourselves, and
kind of being ourselves
and our friendship is on
display and that kind of thing.
It's a different kind of entertainment
than something that's,
because the conceptual
stages are happening
with the writing team and
producers and on purpose.
It's like we're not trying
to like throw ourselves back
into GMM creatively.
We're throwing ourselves
into other places creatively.
But then after a while, you're like, well,
we used to at least have like
a sketch or a music video
or something like that
that would get out there.
And it's a different process
of throwing that out into the world
and having people react to it.
So I think that our reaction
to feeling a little bit restricted
in that way is to say, "Well,
let's put something out there."
You know? (laughing)
And so that-
- I don't want to build it up too much
because it's not gonna be anything
that they can predict.
- Yeah.
I agree with that.
- So if you think anything
that you could predict
and would then you would get
excited about, don't do it
'cause it's not that type of thing.
- Right.
- But we're excited about it
and I'm gonna leave it at that.
I'm gonna make a recommendation.
You know, you had your creative book
which I'm actually listening to it.
I'm not that far into it, but
I really appreciated early on
she talks about fear
being a barrier to creativity.
- Yeah.
- I was going in a
record shop and I found,
I knew this existed and then I'd forgotten
and then I remembered, so I picked it up.
Questlove wrote a creative book
called "Creative Quest."
A creativity book is what I meant to say.
I'm not all the way through this thing.
I skipped to the last chapter
so that it could inform,
success and failure is
one of the last chapters.
And so I'm a big fan of Questlove.
Honored to have met him in the halls of,
actually we met him,
we didn't meet him on the
halls of "The Tonight Show."
We met him during the day.
We just met him during the show.
- I mean, Questlove played
drums for us to rap.
- Isn't that crazy?
- Our eighth grade-
- Questlove is awesome.
- Eight grade talent show,
Halloween fall festival thing.
It's crazy.
- So "Creative Quest," fun book.
It talks about, you know,
it's his relationship with creativity,
and the thing that got me
was is his opening line
"Decades into my career with many albums
and songs under my belt,
I still don't know if I am truly creative.
Most days I spend more time absorbing
the creative work around me
than actually creating myself.
At times, I feel like
I'm a way better student
than I am a teacher or a maker."
And that really resonated with me.
I think a lot of what I
said just a few seconds ago
about, you know, that's a
testimony to our teamwork,
that we will talk about
with the Enneagram.
That was like, okay, a guy
who is undeniably creative
has this doubt in his mind
if he would call himself that
because of the way that he engages
with the creative world is different.
So if you're into Questlove,
if that resonates with you,
"Creative Quest" is my recommendation.
- Tell us about your
experience with creativity,
failure, rejection.
#EarBiscuits.
Biscuits, that's what we're
calling it now, ear biscuits.
- This has been a longer one.
- Yeah.
- We love to talk about how much we suck.
- Join us, join us next week
as we finally into the Enneagram.
(upbeat music)
- [Link] To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.